okay we'll get started I've got
everything turned on here so a couple of
things I've been mentioning that it's
really kind of cool I think at this
stage where you've gathered enough steam
in some of the topics that many things
that come out in the news mate start
looking of interest or relevant to you
and I found this it was ad it had a news
brief in the scientist and then I went
to the original paper which is in Nature
Biotechnology and if you recall towards
the end of the work on proteins we were
talking about phenylketonuria which is a
genetic li linked disorder where people
cannot metabolize phenylalanine to keep
the levels of phenylalanine in check so
what happens is the phenylalanine gets
converted to a toxic material and it
causes a lot of fundamental physiologic
disorders that moves a lot of neurologic
disorders so what a small company in the
area called what's the name of the
company I can see it here anyway
sin logic is a synthetic biology company
which basically engineers bacterial
strains as probiotics that can be used
to mitigate some genetic disorders and
so they've created a bacterial strain
that can metabolize phenylalanine so do
a good job of sort of not letting your
phenylalanine levels get too high so in
the in the GI system this bacterium
basically works on phenylalanine to
metabolize it so that then people don't
have to lead such a strict dietary
regime don't and have way less risk so I
think it's a really cool thing this
probiotic is in one to clinical trials
it's being fast-tracked and the company
in general is a synthetic biology
company working on solutions to certain
types of diseases that could either save
you from having a lot of restrictions on
the way on your lifestyle or
alternatively save you from taking
medications and stuff so that's
something that that caught my eye I want
to remind you that I have now put the
link to the scientist in the sidebar of
the website so it's much easier for you
to grab it and take a look what's in the
news there's stuff in the news every two
or three days and there are things that
I think you'll find interesting that
really relate to technology engineering
and fundamental science that are related
to biology the other thing I want to do
is remind you that towards the last the
end of the class but you know time like
the present because it is a sort of the
equivalent of one of the problem sets
but in fact worth a little bit more than
the problem set is I want to encourage
you to keep an eye on the scientist link
and maybe pick out a topic that two or
three of you would like to write a news
brief on with a paragraph of writing on
introduction and what the technology is
how technology has addressed a
particular scientific or biological
problem and then there should also be a
graphic but describes it not stuff
snipped out of whatever you're reading
something that you create as a team to
scribe a concept to people there's
alternatives with that assignment you
can also pick an interesting protein
from the PDB make a 3d print a bit learn
how to print it and go to the 3d
printers in the maker labs and print the
protein and then write a brief summary
of what it is and one other idea I had
for the engineers of U is I would love a
better less clunky to topoisomerase
demonstration in particular I'd really
like one where you can snip the pieces
apart let the untangling happen and put
them back together so some of you could
work with a couple of colleagues and you
make something which I know a lot of you
are really keen on which is why your
engineers alright okay any questions
about any of this I'm trying to make
sure that this doesn't creep up on you
it's just something you do it's great to
get awareness
of Technology in the but in the life
sciences because of how much
contribution it makes so if you keep an
eye on things you won't be forced to
suddenly find something good at the last
minute you'll just have found something
and go that's the perfect thing to
describe alright questions and the other
thing is if you if you're not unsure you
can always let us know what you've
chosen or what you think you're gonna
choose and the chat with us and we'll
say yeah it looks like looks like a good
idea okay so let's move forward now all
right so what I want to do first of all
is just remind you it kind of flew by a
little bit that DNA replication is
bi-directional okay so what that means
is wherever you have an origin of
replication you can replicate in two
directions and I was sort of falling
asleep thinking about this I sure wonder
what happens at the other side of the
circular plasmid when the machineries
kind of collide and you spit out a brand
new copy of a circular chunk of DNA but
don't think about that too much would
probably keep you awake too much so this
is circular DNA so what organisms have
circular DNA prokaryotes that remember
the eukaryotic DNA is linear and
actually we're going to talk about a
conundrum with the eukaryotic DNA
because of the ends of the DNA the ends
of the chromosomes and they're copying
when we talk about telomerase but this
is typical of a bacterial circular DNA
it's usually super coiled and becomes
uncoiled in order to be replicated so
obviously going by directionally gives
you twice the speed because you're
roaring around the same time the
helicase opens up the DNA DNA polymerase
does its job the pink strand here would
be the leading strand and there's gob
viously going to be one on both strands
of DNA which will replicate very well
but don't
forget you're going to have to deal with
the lagging strands in both cases so in
both cases what you would do ooop
station
you stick down a primer in order to be
able to build those lagging strands
otherwise DNA polymerase can't get a
grip on the double-stranded DNA in order
to carry out the synthesis so in those
cases there would be a primer to set up
the lagging strand and then DNA
synthesis can occur so let's put that in
once there's a primer here DNA synthesis
can occur and then what happens with
respect to the pieces that we're dealing
with what do you what happens with the
primer what do we have to do to get to a
nice complete intact strand of DNA which
enzymes are involved yeah here there
would be like A's activity we need that
what about at the other end what do we
do with the primer and then how can we
move forward someone else what happens
with the primer if it's it's oftentimes
an RNA primer you'll see in a moment
that RNA doesn't need a prime a so it's
very easy for RNA polymerase to stitch
in little pieces what do we have to do
though to get an intact strand of DNA
okay yep so you're gonna remove the RNA
then the polymerase later on when we
keep going can sort of build this piece
and then we'll have to ligate that as
well
so you want to remember all the
functions of those enzymes that are
involved in replication it's a little
worrisome that people I know you don't
want to talk or you think that's an
obvious answer but it's really important
that you have them at your fingertips
some of these enzymes that are involved
in this process because they should
start to become second
nature when you have to make a full DNA
copy of an entire genome there's a lot
of moving parts but if you start walking
through the logic of them they make
sense if I'm gonna unpeel DNA I need a
helicase if I'm gonna keep it
single-stranded I need single strand
binding proteins if I'm gonna move
forward sure I need the polymerase but
what does the polymerase need it
sometimes needs a needs a primer in
order to have double strand because DNA
polymerase only wants to lock on to a
double strand to go start doing its job
these complications with the lagging
strands that are really annoying but
it's pretty remarkable Nature has
addressed this and is able remember to
replicate DNA in bacteria at a speed of
100 base pairs per second so that's
what's going on this entire processor
excuse me a thousand base pairs a second
I just want you to remember this process
is slower in eukaryotes it's about 30 to
50 base pairs per second obviously when
you're speeding you make more mistakes
so there are more mistakes in bacterial
genome replication what what is why does
it not matter so much if there's a
mistake in a bacterial genome right what
do you know about bacteria and their
lifestyles do they stick around a long
time no so they divide quickly they live
and die quickly so you're not having to
keep an intact genome without mistakes
in it for a long time because you're
just turning over back to if there's a
mistake it probably dies out or heaven
forbid there's resistance to drugs
developed and we'll talk about those
later because those occur due to
mistakes in in bacterial replication but
in a eukaryotic genome we have to
preserve the integrity of the genome so
I'm going to talk about two things that
are related to the accuracy of
replication now because that's a really
important component
right so the first thing is to think
about what's the basal rate of making
mistakes of DNA polymerase so for that
purpose I'm just gonna put down a piece
of DNA with its partner that's being
synthesized 5 prime to 3 Prime and I'll
put in some bases so a so that would
have had a T put in opposite G that
would have had a c p-- so these have two
hydrogen bonds these have 3 hydrogen
bonds and let's say we now have a C here
so we want to put in a G at the position
opposite DNA polymerase wants to add the
next the next base pair it should be a G
because it's going in opposite a C it's
being grown in the right direction 5
prime to 3 prime so the basal error rate
is about a thousand to one so a thousand
999 times out of a thousand the right
base gets put in one time out of a
thousand you might put in the wrong rate
so the error rate is about one in ten to
three that's really all that's all
that's at play here is energetics just
how favorable putting in the right base
is but there's a slight chance that the
wrong base will just go in because yeah
that's the the energetics are
sufficiently different but you're gonna
make mistakes just because of thermo the
thermodynamic balance if you're putting
in 999 you're gonna get it wrong some of
the time just statistically because
they're the difference in energy between
putting in the right base or putting in
a wrong base so that error rate is too
high if we replicated our genome 32
billion base pairs we had an one in ten
to the three error rate we have a lot of
mistakes in the genome right
and we cannot tolerate that because all
those mistakes in our genome will then
propagate to mistakes in our proteome if
we're in the right segments of the
genome so this is pretty unacceptable
with respect to an error rate so one way
that nature deals with this is the DNA
polymerase actually does some
proofreading all right so it has a
proofreading function so what do you do
when you're proofreading you take a
quick look at what you've just written
and say oh yeah that looks good that
looks good
so what DNA polymerase is it more or
less reaches back to the base it puts in
and check the checks that it's okay it
can only proofread one base back it
can't proofread from work that's been
done a long time ago it can just
proofread very recent work and if it
looks like it's the wrong base DNA
polymerase has an opposite function it
has what's known as a three prime
exonuclease activity so I'll write that
down and then we'll talk about what that
means three prime and so nucleates
so let's say we put in instead of G we
put in a T that's bad news so what they
can do is it can reach back and cut off
from the three prime end a single
nucleotide just the one that just got
put in alright and then allow the
process to reoccur to get the right base
pairing so a lot of enzymes will
catalyze both forwards and backwards
reactions DNA polymerase the energetics
of such are that it will is able to
catalyze both the addition of a
nucleotide and the removal of a single
nucleotide only if it's at the three
prime end only if it's at an open end
it's just been put in so that remember
the DNA polymerase is still here because
its plan is to move forward and keep on
putting in nucleotides but he actually
checks back you could picture DNA
polishes sort of quickly looking over
its shoulder at the work it's just done
and realizing that's the wrong one so
what this does is brings the Riera rates
down considerably goes in one in ten for
the five so that's way better one in a
hundred thousand is much better and
that's pretty acceptable so it means
you're really making very minimal
mistakes in the replication okay so this
apart the proofreading brings the error
rate from one in 10 to the 3 10 to the 3
to 1 in 10 to the 5 but it can only work
during trans doing DNA polymerase
activity and it can only work on the
most recent nucleotide that has been put
in so this is basically a summary of yes
question they are and they are similar
they're similar actually there's
slightly less error rates in eukaryotes
because the speed is slower so the
opportunity to fix things is going to be
a little bit better so in the end you
your goal really is to bring your error
rate between 10 to the 5 and 10 to the 6
but for bacteria because this speed is
so much larger this is sort of the down
with the limit of it but in Eukarya it
can be a little bit better because the
speed is slower so you could imagine if
you're quickly proofreading you're doing
a less good job than if you're slowly
proofreading but the enzymes that I'll
talk to you about in a second in Eukarya
are to fix entire work that's already
been done we'll see that in a moment and
that's what really cleans up these
enzymes are called the guardians of the
genome so it's and they're much more
sophisticated in Eukarya ok so it's very
good point all right so here's the the
general plot of the general scheme
there is an extension there's a mistake
so there's proofreading the mistake gets
taken out and then you keep on extending
again all right
so this now becomes pretty pretty good
but what we need to talk about now is
what are the enzymes that go to work and
I'm leaving what's on that border there
because I'm going to come back to it to
actually correct mistakes in DNA so
let's talk about the guardians of the
genome because remember that your DNA is
your permanent record of what needs to
be made all right so the types of
mistakes that can be fixed with roof
reading are only recent mistakes the
types of enzymes are going to talk to
you about a mistakes that are found
globally within double-stranded DNA and
these are mistakes wherever they may be
mistakes that didn't get corrected by
proofreading but more importantly
they're mistakes that occur due to some
kind of damage on the D on the DNA so
what kind of things might impact the
integrity of our DNA on a day to day
basis yeah
sunlights so terrible stuff UV light
will actually cause some cross links
that and I'll show you one of those that
are very serious in DNA what else might
hurt the Dean of the genome so sunlight
people say don't go in the Sun like that
right about that what else yeah the
radiation is another form so that's some
like radioactivity radiation is
important right so if our ozone layer
gets thin there's more risk there as
well what about barbeque yeah yeah awful
chemicals right so chemicals
so these are things like poly poly
aromatic structures that actually slip
into your genome and cause mistakes in
the reading or they actually physically
modify the basis to make it a base that
doesn't look like a base anymore so
these are commonly very reactive
chemicals these are all very serious
things to the genome and so the the
enzymes that mitigate the damage to the
DNA basically screen along the
double-stranded DNA to look for defects
because if you have perfectly paired DNA
then you're not you're gonna have a very
regular structure whereas if something
has happened to the DNA there's
something wrong with the base it's not
base pairing well or something has
actually happened between bases where
they're causing a bulge in the genome
then these enzymes will come into play
and about a few years ago actually it
was one on a class day so I always enjoy
these there was a the Nobel Prize was
awarded in 12 2015 for the researchers
who deciphered the mechanisms for
correcting the genome through DNA repair
mechanisms so there are two basic
mechanisms that I'll talk to you about
one is base excision repair
and the other one has to be is a lot
more serious it's actually the entire
nucleotide excision repair so one fixes
just the base that's gone wrong but the
other one takes much more of the
structure out to fix it so it's
nucleotide excision repair so BER and
we're gonna talk about both of those
mechanisms because they're very
fascinating and they kind of lean on
some of what you've learnt already so
base excision repair occurs when there's
a defect in the base maybe it's the
wrong base maybe it's just been modified
a little bit so what happens in base
excision repair is that the base gets
alright I'm going to just use the
pointer because my little spotlight
it'll pop back it's a bit magical so in
base excision repair only the base a
single localized base is damaged there
is some chemistry for example that will
convert cytosine to uracil called a
deamination mechanism and in fact once
if you replace a cytosine with a uracil
then you get in trouble with respect to
its base pairing with its appropriate
purine partner so in base excision
repair what will happen is that base
will be detected it will be flicked out
from the context of double-stranded DNA
if it's tucked in the double stranded
DNA
you can't quite cut the bond that's
attached from the ribose sugar to the
base so the base gets flipped out of the
DNA structure and there's an enzyme
known as a glycosylase that cuts the
bond between the ribose and the base and
gets rid of it and then what happens is
the rest of the nucleotide just that one
nucleotide gets removed and then DNA
polymerase fills the gap and the strand
is sealed by a ligase so glycosylase
cuts the base out there's a couple
there's a couple of enzymes that
actually cut the ribose the
phosphodiester linkages out
and then the two enzymes remember that
are important when we're making DNA the
the polymerase and the ligase cut work
together to put a base in to this
position and then they put they put the
base back in and then the ligase joins
the gaps so DNA polymerase will make one
of the bonds the ligase will make the
other bond all right so that's nuclear
that's base excision repair and it's
monitored by finding that there is a
lack of integrity in the double-stranded
DNA it's only a base that's affected so
that base gets removed the rest of the
nucleotide is removed but only one of
them and then they're replaced through
the concerted action of polymerase and
ligase now there is another mechanism
that's much more serious and this is
very typical of the types of damage that
get formed from sunlight and UV
radiation is when two Thema Dean's and
adjacent to each other they will undergo
quite commonly a chemical reaction where
they form a dimeric structure so there's
much more wrong with the the nuclei of
the DNA strand in that situation so
those get noticed as things driving me
nuts
those get noticed as a real defect in
the DNA base excision repair won't work
why wouldn't it work yeah yeah they're
bound together you can't peel them back
out you can't break enough structure so
you've got to move to a much more sort
of major fixing of the the of the DNA
strand so there is a genetically linked
disorder where the enzymes involved in
nucleotide excision repair do not work
and when people when a child has a copy
of both the affected genes from the
parents both one from the mother and the
father it's impossible for them to fix
these defects in the da
and they get a lot of physiologic
problems like sort of scarring and some
burns nothing barely anything at all and
so this is this is a group of children
that are so afflicted with this new this
genetic disorders that they cannot go
out in the daytime at all
so you're sometimes see they're called
children of the night because basically
they have to flip their schedules they
just can't go near sunlight and if they
go out they basically have to be covered
from head to toe and that's including
their eyes because you can get sunburned
of the eyes you can sort of see in some
of these pictures that looks really
serious defects and this is just the
external manifestation the entire
manifestation would be cases of skin
cancer very very readily so if you don't
have at least one good copy of the
enzyme that does nucleotide excision
repair then you're in trouble and the
defects are called
is called xeroderma pigmentosum and
there's actually a lot of family groups
that get together because the best way
is just to form a sort of social network
so the children understand what each
other the limitations that they all have
and they can play together and beyond
these sort of flip schedules in order to
avoid any sunlight so in this case it's
essential to basically clip out a large
chunk of the DNA so what happens in this
case is that the DNA is recognized and
then a large portion of it about a dozen
nucleotides are cleaved out and then
once again DNA polymerase fills the gap
and DNA ligase seals the last gaps so
DNA polymerase will be able to fill
going from the 5 prime to 3 prime
they'll still be one gap and then the
ligase fixes it so I think these kinds
of things that are done to mitigate
damage on the genome are very important
to understand because this is happening
all the time any minor things that get
fixed the need fixing due to sunlight
radiation chemicals will will be fixed
through these methods to keep that rate
that error rate in your genome down to
like one in a billion or something like
that alright so I'm just gonna flash
this up I'm gonna very quickly I'm gonna
give you guys what a copy of this but
these are the components that you want
to be able to understand the function of
oops
when thinking about DNA replication so
you don't have that on your slides but
we're going to give you a copy so that
you can really make sure that you
understand all the moving parts and how
to they come together for replication
now I want to talk about one last
conundrum with DNA and that is the issue
of telomerase and this is particularly
critical in eukaryotes that have linear
chromosomes now if you think about DNA
being replicated what when you look at
the two strands of DNA as you approach
the as you approach the very end of the
chromosome you'll do just fine
making the copy that's built five primes
that's built worried about this
you'll do just fine making the copy that
is built in this direction because it's
the leading strand and it's built by
prime am I going wrong here it's built
five prime to three prime can someone
help me out here I'm losing my mind okay
this is so this piece is built five
prime to three prime so therefore this
was five-prime and three-prime but then
on the other strand you have a problem
because you need to put in a primer here
in order to build the other strand does
that make sense so we've got to have put
in that short primer because DNA polymer
is will not work otherwise and then we
need to build this strand of DNA all
right so what's the problem here with
respect to these ends what's gonna
happen next it's an RNA primer what
happens next
we nibble it up right with the full
intention of replacing that bit of day
in the DNA but then what can DNA
polymerase do it can't do anything right
DNA polymerase needs double-stranded DNA
to hold on to so it could fill this gap
so what happens is every time you
replicate DNA you end up with a gap with
a small amount you don't quite copy is
everyone following me and that's a
problem right because doesn't it mean
every time my cells divide my genes get
a little bit shorter and a little bit
shorter and a little bit shorter so
there are things in place that help one
important feature is that usually you
don't have important genetic material at
the ends of your genes
at the ends of chromosomes rather
there's sort of extra DNA that doesn't
need to be copied but the basic theory
the whole theory about telomerase is
that for certain types of cells these
are sent stem cells and germ cells there
is an enzyme that can fill this gap
it's called telomerase so in those cells
what's special about these types of
cells we need to keep them good there
what defines your starting DNA the stem
cells and the and the germ cells like in
this sperm and egg have to have in have
to have a good copy of DNA they can't be
getting shorter and shorter every time a
new generation is born but once your
cells are the somatic cells the DNA gets
shorter and shorter because the those
cells don't have telomerase and this is
associated with theories of aging so the
cells you get the ones that are finally
the ones in your body every time they
divide the ends of the chromosomes will
get a little shorter but there's no
mechanism to replace those and so it's
associated with the belief that at a
certain stage you've divided the cells
enough times and then you can't they
you're actually starting to nibble in
two important coding DNA does everybody
understand that what would be the
significance of that does that make
sense yeah
No so the telomerase keeps the the the
DNA in those types of cells in good
condition in the cells that divide daily
in your body once these are the somatic
cells you will keep on shortening but
they'll just be more mistakes basically
and those are the sorts of things that
would be associated with an organism
that's growing to a certain age because
there's just a certain number of cells
so the cells may not divide or there may
be mistakes in certain parts of the
coding genome anything any other
questions okay so
Kalama raised was also another important
discovery that was awarded a nobel prize
and this gives you details so the
telomerase is protects the genetic
information on every cell division
though you will you will lose a little
bit of genetic information so it limits
the number of divisions a cell can make
in a lifetime alright so we're gonna
move on now and I've spent quite a bit
of time on this but I want to guarantee
you that we're now as we move forward to
transcription there's a few
simplifications that we can make in the
in the story of transcription so moving
on alright so what have we done so far
we've seen replication now we're moving
to the process of transcription
so when you transcribe something you're
basically making a copy of something but
in a slightly different format so for
example if you're transcribing from
handwritten to a typed version you go
from something that's in the script to
something that's typed it has the same
content but it's in a different format
so this is that what the process is
called when you convert DNA into RNA and
very specifically this is part of the
process to make what's known as the
messenger RNA the first phase of
transcription in eukaryotic cells gets
us to a pre messenger RNA so there's a
little bit needs more needs to be done
to it before it can leave the nucleus to
encode protein translation but in
bacteria you're basically just going
straight from the DNA to the messenger
RNA at the beginning of the next class
we will also talk about going from the
pre messenger RNA to the messenger RNA
and let's take a look at the cell up
here where what we're focusing in on
here is the process whereby we're
copying that DNA I have no idea why this
is really being monstrously behaved like
I'm done done with these gizmos the
process whereby the double-stranded DNA
opens up a little bit and we make that
pre messenger RNA copy alright so I want
you to think back to the processes that
we learnt about for translation and now
we're going to move forward to take a
look at transcription and frankly it's a
lot simpler so let's just look at the
players in transcription and you've got
a copy of this in your notes so I don't
need to necessarily put it all on the
board so in DNA remember we had a GC T
we have a deoxyribose and it's mostly
used as
ready Terry genetic information but in
RNA we're making a new copy of the DNA
where we use slightly different building
blocks a GC u u instead of T plus there
are some modified bases that occur in
some of the types of RNA and the sugar
is a ribose so the first main thing
about the RNA copy relative to the DNA
copy is that ribose deoxyribose
difference what's quite remarkable is
that when you have two deoxyribose in
your DNA it's nice and stable we need it
to be nice and stable
it's our genome we can't let our genome
be falling apart as we're sort of
walking down the street in contrast when
RNA is used it's much more transient we
make a messenger RNA copy of part of DNA
to move forward to make proteins but we
don't need that to stick around forever
and when you have the ribose with the 2
hydroxyl zat 2 & 3 it's a much more
fragile material it is a transient
message and it's got it gets degraded
quite quickly so that difference in the
sugar really dictates the stability that
RNA is found in a lot of polymers
biopolymers will talk will focus mostly
on the messenger RNA and RNA today it's
about 1 less than 1% of the DNA and then
on Friday we'll be talking about the
transfer RNA and the ribosomal RNA so
we're really gonna focus in right now on
the messenger RNA and the one thing
about RNA structures I'm will elaborate
later is they have very different
structures two canonical DNA which are
drops the double-stranded anti parallel
structure RNA structures are much more
like folded protein structures where
there may be sections of base pairing
but there'll also be lots of loops and
different characteristics so even the
ribose structure makes a difference in
the stability of the double-stranded
structure and encourages a lot more of
these unusual structures which
really why people have a lot of faith in
the in the theories about the RNA world
okay so let's look at DNA polymerase RNA
polymerase so here's the here's all the
good news that we'll be able to describe
to you okay so when you copy DNA you
copy all of it when you copy RNA you
only copy when you make the copy of
messenger RNA you only copy about 1.5
percent of the genome so you do not copy
the entire thing so the process is much
more restricted to sections of DNA that
needs to be copied and we'll talk about
the the features of the DNA that tell
you about that later okay here's the
important details so in eukaryotes
transcription happens in the nucleus and
the key enzyme involved is RNA
polymerase RNA pol and there it has very
different features to DNA polymerase but
there are two big things that are
different it includes its own helicase
so you remember with replication we
needed a DNA polymerase and the helicase
RNA polymerase is much smarter than that
it actually includes both functions
within its structure so it's an RNA
polymerase the grows the new nucleotide
5 prime to 3 prime but it also has a
built-in helicase so that's an advantage
it still grows the messenger RNA 5 prime
to 3 prime but it uses the different
nucleotide triphosphate building blocks
or one of them is different so UTP ATP
so remember that you replaces the T in
RNA so that's one key difference it
includes a helicase activity and the
other really neat things because it's
such a complication in replication is it
doesn't require a primer that is why
even when we were replicating the DNA we
were using RNA polymerase to make those
little pieces of primers because it
didn't need prior priming sequence so
there's a really fundamental difference
is about the RNA polymerase and then the
other thing is that only one of the two
strands of DNA is transcribed and in a
moment or maybe the beginning of next
husk will judge how we can understand
which sequence is transcribed and then
obviously the messenger RNA is a
complementary sequence to the sequence
of DNA that is being copied
finally only part of the DNA is
transcribed under unlike the process of
replication all right so you can see
already that there are a lot of
simplifications in transcription that we
did not have the advantage of in
replication so the helicase activity and
the primer issue are two key features
the mate life a lot simpler I just
wanted to show you this small detail
about RNA polymerase there are a lot of
natural products out there that are
known to be inhibitors of vital
processes and one that caught my eye is
the the ends I of the small molecules
that are found in mushrooms the really
toxic mushrooms when you see some of
these in fact never eat a mushroom that
that you don't know and you know where
it came from because there's problems
with them because a lot of these
mushrooms include potent natural
products
and in fact there's a compound known as
a Manton alpha a mountain and it's found
in a in certain mushrooms known as
either the death cap or destroying angel
mushrooms so you could tell from their
names that they are a real problem and
what the mountain does is it actually
interferes directly with RNA polymerase
by acting as an allosteric inhibitor of
RNA polymerase and locking it into a
closed state so it can't keep on
transcribing so I thought this was very
interesting incredibly like one you know
tiny tiny tiny doses will hold a rest
transcription and cause your and cause
dire consequences so I think what's very
interesting is that it's it's an
allosteric inhibitor it's very potent
and what it does is it seals the
polymerase in a locked closed state that
it can't move forward for transcriptions
okay now finally the couple of points
when we decide that a portion of gene is
going to be transcribed there are a lot
of mechanisms in place to identify the
portion of that gene and one of the key
things that is known is that there are
what are called promoter sites which are
actually upstream of the portion of gene
that's to be transcribed where you
recruit a bunch of proteins that
actually Park down on the
double-stranded DNA and then at the end
of the day recruits the RNA polymerase
so all that extra genome some of it is
not transcribed into messenger RNA for
making proteins but it's part of an area
of the gene that gets recognized by all
of the proteins that collaborate to
bring in the RNA polymerase in order for
your RNA to be transcribed so what I'm
showing you here is a stranded
double-stranded DNA with one of the very
common promoters that's just upstream of
the part of the DNA that gets
transcribed and it's called the tata box
because it's ta ta sequence it's
appalling it's got a complement that
looks like
and it's shown in pink here and then the
ends I are the proteins that bind to the
DNA at the tata box actually drape over
that segment of double-stranded DNA and
then serve as recruitment entities to
bring in all the machinery that's needed
for transcription of the gene beyond it
so some of the identity of all that
extra double-stranded DNA is actually as
guide places to guide where the
machinery for transcription has to Park
in order for a messenger RNA to be
formed so immediately you can see we're
only going to transcribe part of this
genetic material beyond here but we need
a whole bunch of genetic material that's
actually just serving as sort of the
runway for the plane landing in the
right position all right so I'm going to
put up the puzzle that you can think
about and then we'll start with these at
the beginning of the next class because
I don't want to rush them when you
decide to transcribe a gene let's say
you've got a promoter site here the
thing that I want you to think about is
which strand would you transcribe and
what's the logic behind this and then
we'll just do a recap on this at the
beginning of the next class because I
just want you to think about it because
the information a lot of the information
you need is directly here hi there we're
just wrapping up okay so that's it for
today
you